david les députés ont donc donné ce
matin leur ultime validation oui dans un
hémicycle quasi vide et une atmosphère
moins électrique que lors de la première
lecture au mois de novembre le texte a
été adopté avec 75 voix pour et 33
contre sur un total de 112 votants le
vote de cette proposition de loi était
fortement boycotter un par l'opposition
après des mois de tractations de
contestation populaire la réécriture
dans sa quasi totalité du texte de cette
proposition loi sur la sécurité globale
par le sénat n'a rien changé aux
revendications de la coordination contre
cette proposition de loi qui réunit
syndicats de journalistes et
organisations de défense de la liberté
il réclame toujours le retrait de ce
texte est comme bon nombre de députés
c'est le cas notamment les gérards le
seul député socialiste écoutez je pense
que le gouvernement n'a pas pris la
mesure de ce côté liberticide qui est
ressenti par une grande partie de la
population de ce texte y compris à
travers la réécriture de l'article 24
mai malgré tout ce n'est pas aujourd'hui
satisfaisant pour une partie des
parlementaires une partie des députés
qui ont voté contre ce texte et donc
nous différons le texte au conseil
constitutionnel en première lecture bon
nombre de l'élu d'intel même de la
majorité s'étaient abstenus c'était le
cas également cet après-midi sacha où il
est dépité de là
un république en marche estime que de
nombreux points aurait dû être encore
débattues
d'abord c'est un texte qui a fait
l'objet d'un accord entre le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale
moi je le dis en d'autant plus que je
n'ai pas voté ce texte me suis abstenu
c'est un texte qui était beaucoup
discuté qui aurait mérité de l'être
encore
qui pour ce qui concerne les mesures du
continuum de sécurité c'est à dire pour
les mesures qui mutualisent les
compétences des polices nationales
locales de la gendarmerie a un intérêt
pour ce qu'il oblige en termes de
déontologie ou d'encadrement de la
sécurité privée
ah et aussi un intérêt et pour ce qui
crée une police municipale à paris est
tout à fait judicieux en revanche sur l
usage des drones sur la façon dont on a
accès aux images que l'on capte en
direct ou sur le port d'armes de
policiers hors de leurs fonctions dans
des établissements publics là je pense
qu'il y avait des choses qui méritaient
d'être revus mais qui ne l'ont pas été à
savoir qu avant sa promulgation
officielle la proposition de loi sur la
sécurité globale devra passer devant le
conseil constitutionnel comme l'a promis
elle à gauche et comme l'avait a annoncé
jean castex en novembre lors de la
première lecture ici même ou pas les
bons merci beaucoup d'avis de khalifa